Build it, draw it, play it
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people. This
is BiDiPi.
Build it
Tom Miller built a personal train track that
runs around his nearly 20 acre property. It
has handmade steam locomotives, 11,000 feet
of track, 30 ft tall railroad trestle, anda
400 foot long tunnel. He also has two of the
largest F scale trains in his museum that
were build completely by hand, including all
of the scenery and background.
Randall Rosenthal creates amazing wooden sculptures
that look like paper objects. All of his projects
start from a single block of wood and are
hand-painted once carved. Some of his work
includes a cardboard box full of cash, newspapers,
box full of baseball cards, and binders full
of papers.
Mister Finch isa self-taught artist that
sews nature-inspired original creations. They
look similar to taxidermy and he uses recycled
materials to make them. Some of his works
include Tea Making Spider, Halloween Hares,
and Felinka- a larger sculpture made from
leather and fake fur.
Brett Kern creates these hyper-realistic ceramic
sculptures that look like inflatable toys.
The work ranges from inflatable dinosaurs
to balloons and a space man. He sells them
on his etsy page and it takes at least a month
to handmake them to order.
Draw it
Emptied Gestures is a body art project by
Heather Hansen. Each life-sized drawing is
created by holding charcoal in each hand and
making choreographed movements across the
paper. She says she's looking for ways to
download her movement directly onto paper,
emptying gestures from one form to another.
Michael Mapes creates these intricate collage
portraits out of scientific specimens. He
uses parts of photographic prints, glass vials,
insect pins, dried botanical matter, and other
materials to create his works inspired by
Dutch painters.
And now for some pieces from the Art of Tolkien
series by Jian Guo.
BreakThru films is creating the world's first
feature length painted animation about the
life of Vincent Van Gogh. It's told entirely
through his paintings and the characters in
them. 56,800 paintings will be made by the
films 40 painters in order to create the finished
piece.
Play it
Composer JohnnyRandom created Bespoken - music
made only using sounds from his bike.
Jackson Parodi does cover songs with his accordion
here's his version of Those Who Fight from
Final Fantasy 7.
Direct from Norway here's ice used as an instrument
at the Ice Concert in Geilo.
Finally here's the official video for "Can't
see U" by Lenkemz featuring Slick Don with
animation by Prefix Studios.
Submit your BiDiPis as personal message here
on YouTube. Or share them with everyone over
at Facebook.com/VsauceTWO.
Click here to listen to a brand new installment
of BiDiPi Radio. Music created and submitted
by you guys. Also check out YOUR BiDiPi. An
entire video dedicated to only your creations.
And as always - thanks for watching.